de dérouler ce journal on s'arrête
quelques instants sur cette toute
dernière information un journaliste
américain a été tué par balle ce
dimanche à herpines s'étend en
périphérie nord de Kief la capitale
notre confrère s'appelle Brent on en
parle avec vous au Bilal TArabie bonjour
Bilal merci d'être là est-ce qu'on en
sait un petit peu plus sur les
circonstances de la disparition de la
mort de notre confrère alors écoutez
c'est c'est pas clair et pour l'instant
il faut prendre ces informations avec
avec précaution ce qu'on sait d'abord et
ça c'est selon le médecin
ukrainien qui a constaté son décès c'est
que Brent Renaud circulait en voiture
dans irpin
Brent Reno n'était pas seul il était
dans la voiture avec un autre
journaliste américain on sait pas s'il
travaillait ensemble ou s'ils étaient
juste dans la même zone ou comme on dit
sur sur le même terrain et ils étaient
avec un civil ukrainien dans cette
voiture donc pareil on ne sait pas
finalement si c'était leur guide ou un
comme on dit exactement dans notre
jargon la personne qui guide les
journalistes évidemment dans des zones à
travers à travers le monde et on sait
pas ou alors s'il était un par si
c'était un partisan si c'était un
milicien si c'était un soldat ukrainien
donc ils étaient à irpn je pense qu'on
va pouvoir voir la carte des environs de
de Kiev pour situer yerpine voilà
girpine c'est ici on est à quinzaine de
kilomètres de Kiev et c'est ce verrou en
fait qui tient le front nord-ouest de la
capitale quand je l'ai dit qu'il tient
c'est parce que ça fait plusieurs jours
et vous avez pu aussi le voir sur notre
antenne que les combats sont extrêmement
extrêmement dures à irpin c'est un peu
le dernier mur de résistance du côté
non-ouest avant d'arriver à la à la
capitale ukrainienne donc ils étaient en
voiture Brent Renaud était en voiture
avec cet autre journaliste américain et
civil ukrainien lorsque ils auraient
essuyé des tirs alors les autorités
ukrainiennes accusent les Russes
les Russes pour le moment n'ont pas
réagi
or n'a pas de confirmation si vous
voulez à ce stade de de l'exact
enchaînement des événements ou du
scénario qui a amené à la à la mort de
Brent Renaud Brent Renaud est décédé
l'autre journaliste américain a été
blessé aux dernières nouvelles il est
que blessé fait il est toujours en vie
et le civil ukrainien également est
toujours en vie on va revenir quelques
instants sur les éléments Bilal dont on
dispose pour tenter d'en savoir un petit
peu plus sur qui était Brent Renaud on
imagine qu'il était sur place comme de
nombreux confrères comme nos équipes
aussi pour couvrir ce conflit tout à
fait alors le chef de la police
régionale donc la police de la de la
capitale à tout d'abord annoncé qu'il
s'agissait en journaliste du New York
Times donc du journal américain de New
York t parce que Brent Renaud portait
selon lui un badge du New York Times il
y a des vidéos sur les photos pardon sur
les réseaux sociaux qui circulent avec
effectivement les photos de se badge
alors on vous les montre pas parce
qu'elles ont pas encore été
authentifiées mais enfin elle montre
effectivement un badge du New York Times
le New York Times lui-même a réagi
bon c'est dit profondément attristé
d'apprendre la mort du journaliste tout
en précisant qu'en fait s'il portait un
badge du New York Times s'il ne
travaillait il n'était pas en mission en
Ukraine pour le New York Times ça c'est
le journal maintenant on pourrait se
dire pourquoi est-ce qu'il portait un
badge du work Times parce que ce sont
des choses qui se font sur des terrains
dangereux particulièrement s'il s'agit
de médias prestigieux ça peut aider pour
traverser des checks pendant et tout
éviter de se faire embêter il y a une
gage de confiance pardon Bilal je vous
coupe au moment où les autorités
ukrainiennes sont assez sur les dents
aussi parce qu'elle redoute des des
personnes infiltrées donc peut-être que
ce badge pouvait être un gage absolument
oui oui de toute manière c'est fait à la
fois pour protéger son porteur et pour
inspirer la la confiance à ces
interlocuteurs vous savez sur les
terrains de conflit c'est extrêmement
important surtout des terrains de
conflit conventionnels de guerre
conventionnelle en fait de de pouvoir
être identifié ce qui pose d'ailleurs la
question de ont-ils été visé parce que
journaliste on sait pas à ce stade s'il
y avait marqué s'il y avait un signe
distinctif quelconque sur la voiture ou
pas ou si simplement ils ont été visés
par ce que les gens de simplement
désiraient pas la présence de cette
voiture
à ce moment-là mais si vous voulez donc
Brent Renaud par ailleurs travaillait la
plupart du temps avec son frère il avait
un nom en fait c'était les Renault
Brothers son frère s'appelle Craig leur
comme on dit boîte de production enfin
disons leur société de journalistes est
basée à Little Rock en arkans donc c'est
pas loin du tout de là où est né Bill
Clinton pour l'anecdote c'est une toute
petite ville au milieu des États-Unis où
ils ont d'ailleurs fondé un festival de
cinéma documentaire il y a quelques il y
a quelques années il faut voir que peu
importe si vous voulez enfin peu importe
disons quelle badge il portait mais
c'est un journaliste qui a été identifié
comme un journaliste américain et il
faut quand même dire à ce stade que
c'est le premier journaliste étranger
qui qui est mort en
Ukraine en tout cas qui est mort qui est
mort et qui est mort par balle et il
faut rappeler qu'on est dans le cadre
d'un d'un conflit un je finirai
là-dessus où il y a extrêmement peu
d'image et donc c'est grâce
aux journalistes qui sont sur le terrain
tous les autres qu'on peut avoir
quelques aperçus de ce qui se passe sur
sur le front Nadia merci beaucoup Bilal
merci pour ce point voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire pour l'heure sur la
disparition de ce journaliste américain